[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels
heute gibt es ein kleines werkzeug video
und warum gibt's dieses werkzeug video
wir haben ja wirklich seit drei jahren
unseren eigenen online shop und immer
wieder kam natürlich die frage sei wie
kannst du nicht mal ein werkzeug
vorstellen
und das habe ich auch schon länger
versprochen und wollte dieses video auch
unbedingt immer machen
jetzt mache ich aber auch aus aktuellem
anlass und zwar bin ich in ganz vielen
facebook gruppen auch mit dabei manchmal
auch inkognito morath ja ich bin einfach
mit dabei und ließ mit und guckt immer
was alle schreiben
und natürlich gibt es da viele viele
meiner zuschauer die wirklich ganz
begeistert sind auch von unseren
produkten
aber es gibt natürlich auch ganz viele
die mich noch nicht kennen die meine
produkte nicht kennen und dann zum
beispiel sagen mensch bei der sally da
sind die produkte irgendwie teurer als
jetzt wo anders und ich möchte es jetzt
heute so ein bisschen erklären und euch
auch einfach mal die unterschiede zeigen
auch wenn ein produkt gleich aussieht
dass es nicht immer eben das gleiche ist
und ich hab da ein paar tipps und tricks
für euch und auch eine kleine geschichte
also hat er nicht version ihrer zeit wie
viele an verheiratet acht jahre war 88
jahre
vor acht jahren habe ich also meinen
ersten eigenen haushalt nomura zusammen
gegründet
und natürlich hat mir am anfang auch
nicht viel geld ich weiß studium morath
auch noch und da muss man sich natürlich
ein bisschen arrangieren und auch
kompromisse eingehen und kann vielleicht
ist eine kaufen und muss auf das andere
noch sparen so wie es eben am anfang ist
und auch bei uns war es so und wir haben
zum beispiel in den acht jahren in denen
wir schon zusammen sind jetzt schon die
dritte waschmaschine den dritten
fernseher
wir hatten einen fehlkauf beim
kinderwagen fehlkauf bei meinen
küchengeräten ich glaub 90 prozent
meiner zuschauer haben einen besseren
backofen als ich hier zu hause
aber ich möchte ich gerade einfach ein
paar tipps geben wie man eben fehlkäufe
vermeiden kann man lernt ja auch mit der
zeit man lernt auch mit der zeit und
klar macht man fehler ich habe auch ganz
viele fehler gemacht
außer natürlich nicht einschätzen wie im
einzel es jetzt konkurrenz
er warf sonic 40
nein war es gut und es ist natürlich so
dass manchmal wirklich auf den ersten
blick alles gleich aussieht aber es ist
eben nicht gleich
und ich möchte euch jetzt anhand von
einigen beispielen zeigen wie man etwas
billiger machen kann und wie man auch
als kunde das ganze erkennen kann
fangen wir mal an mit der
lebensmittelindustrie da zeige ich euch
jetzt anhand von einem ok bisschen
krassen beispiel wie man ein produkt
billiger produzieren kann
also ich mach das jetzt mit der milch
ich hoffe natürlich dass es in der
industrie nicht mit der mensch so
gemacht wird
aber bei anderen produkten weiß man
natürlich dass es so gemacht wird ich
habe zwar einen halben liter vollmilch
und philips dieses glas damit vom
glücklichen bau von glücklichen bauern
und jetzt habe ich hier 200 milliliter
gute form mensch wie kann ich jetzt
dieses produkt billiger machen ganz klar
ich fühle das glas zum beispiel nur bis
zu einem drittel
und ab jetzt praktisch die gleiche
qualität aber weniger drin zum gleichen
preis das ist wie bei einer chips
verpackung zum beispiel ich habe 500
gramm chips die kostet genauso viel wie
200 gramm chips ich hab halt einfach
weniger drin und mit dem frischkäse
warum oder mit meinem frischkäse
der war früher 200 gramm drin dann kam
plötzlich ein neues design und der preis
war immer noch der gleiche immer noch
199 zum beispiel und ich hab dann auf
die verpackung geguckt und 200 nur noch
175 gramm drin statt 200 also das sind
halt leider so ein paar tricks die in
der lebensmittelindustrie stattfinden wo
man einfach als kunde immer darauf
achten muss und vielleicht einfach auf
den 100 gramm preis guckt aber dann das
finde ich sogar noch okay weil ich denke
die qualität bleibt gleich macht hat nur
weniger für den gleichen preis
was natürlich der krassere trick ist das
ist folgender wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel diese milch einfach mit wasser
auffüllen ändert sich optisch für euch
eigentlich rein gar nichts dieses glas
milch sieht genauso aus wie dieses glas
milch nur dass hier im prinzip 70 wasser
drin steckt und da hat man im prinzip
die milch gestreckt dass die qualität
vermindert aber bietet zum gleichen
preis an
und warum erzähle ich euch jetzt gerade
dieses beispiel mit dem gestreckten
lebensmitteln
es geht nämlich gerade um meine wandel
extrakt was ich im shop anbieten und
zwar kamen doch vor kurzem die frage
mich warum hat sich denn der preis
erhöht also vor zwei drei wochen hat
sich der preis um etwa 2 euro erhöht
zwar kommt es daher weil einfach der
vanille preis im letzten jahr wirklich
um 300 prozent gestiegen ist das heißt
es waren ernteausfälle es waren
missernten und so weiter und es ist
natürlich immer angebot und nachfrage
und wenn eben was auffällt steigt der
preis natürlich das ist ganz klar
und bei diesem wandel extrakt wasser so
dass mich dann der hersteller irgendwann
angesprochen hat und gesagt hat marcel i
wir müssen leider den preis erhöhen und
ich habe dann gesagt okay an was liegt
und haben das eben erklärt und jetzt
haben sie mir natürlich angeboten zu
sagen sally wir könnten ja zum beispiel
die menge erniedrigen also verringern
dass wir praktisch nicht mehr 75
milliliter haben sondern zb 50
milliliter aber zum gleichen preis
dann habe ich gesagt okay es war aber
natürlich so ein bisschen
verbrauchertäuschung das mache ich nicht
und dann haben sie mir angeboten das
produkt zu strecken also so wie jetzt in
diesem glas milch einfach mehr wasser
oder in dem fall mehr fett zuzufügen
und das möchte ich auch nicht weil ich
einfach gesagt habe mein mann extrakt
dass ich es im super produkt aus echtem
vanille konzentrat ohne alkohol und ich
möchte dass die qualität gleich bleibt
also blieb mir im prinzip nichts anderes
übrig als den preis anzuheben um eben
die qualität gleichbleibend hoch zu
halten und ich hab das dann in einer
facebook-gruppe erklärt und war dann
wirklich sehr glücklich darüber dass
meine zuschauer natürlich auch über die
ehrlichkeit sich sehr gefreut haben und
dann hat man es einfach verstanden und
ich stehe halt einfach für die qualität
des produkts haben wir noch ein beispiel
aus den lebensmitteln ich habe hier
modelliert schokolade und beim modell
schokolade gibt wirklich ganz ganz viele
verschiedene anbieter und auch hier
nehme ich immer ganz gerne die von deco
back weil einfach hier 25 prozent echte
schokolade mit drin ist und beim motor
show gerade das besondere das echte
schokolade mit drin ist martin tollen
geschmack und natürlich auch diese ganz
besonderen eigenschaften beim
verarbeiten dass sie eben beim kneten
schön weich wird und ich dann
modellieren kann beim aushärten braucht
etwas länger da kann ich länger dran
wurde den arzt wirklich hat super
eigenschaften gibt natürlich auch andere
hersteller bieten das produkt ein paar
cent günstiger an
aber da müssen natürlich auch auf die
verpackung schauen da steckt man
natürlich auch weniger schokolade drin
und das ist genau der punkt wo ich dann
sage lieber nehme ich dann das
qualitativ hochwertige produkt stadt
eben die günstige modelle
rouladen denn wenn man jetzt weniger als
25 prozent schokolade mit drin hat finde
ich es dann eher dem fondant weil man da
einfach viel zucker mit drin hat und
dann finde ich hab mir einfach die
eigenschaften von modell ihr schokolade
verloren das war jetzt nur ein paar
beispiele aber es gibt natürlich auch
ganz ganz viele andere beispiele wie zum
beispiel fertigen blätterteig
den habe ich früher immer ganz gerne
genommen weil ich gesagt habe mensch
blätterteig ist schon bislang aufwendig
mittlerweile hat sich da meiner meinung
auch ein bisschen verändert früher war
da wirklich noch echte butter mit drin
und das macht hätten blätterteig so
besonders
und wenn ich heute auf die verpackungen
schau ist halt wirklich so dass dann die
hochwertige butter oftmals daneben durch
palmöl zum beispiel ausgetauscht wird
was eben bisher günstiger ist als mutter
gleich palmöl ist nichts schlechtes es
gibt ja auch zertifiziertes palmöl ist
schon auch ein gutes produkt aber ich
möchte euch einfach eben darauf
hinweisen schaut einfach auf die
produkte schaut auf die zutaten ganz
krasses beispiel sind auch immer die
aromen wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel sagen
wir mal bei den fertigen keks zeit oder
bei einem fertigen kuchenteig in die
zutatenliste schauen da steht dann kein
vanille extrakt drin keine vanilleschote
sondern vielleicht im besten fall
natürliches vanille aroma das heißt dann
natürliches aroma heißt dieses produkt
muss jetzt nicht besteht auch nicht aus
vanille sondern es besteht aus einem
produkt natürlichen ursprungs das kann
zum beispiel auch holz sein als es hat
nichts mit dem produkt an sich zu tun
und im schlimmsten fall steht dann
natürlich einfach nur aromatische stand
irgendwas künstlich hergestellt in
berlin zum beispiel ihn zum beispiel
genau erstanden halt künstlicher vanille
und hat mit vanille wirklich gar nichts
zu tun und es sind einfach so dinge auf
die man eben gerade beim kauf als kunde
als konsument und als verbraucher
wirklich drauf achten kann
jetzt geht es weiter mit meinem
kochgeschirr da werde ich manchmal
gefragt warum ich denn mit
plastikgeschirr kochen also das
natürlich der ganz falsche begriff denn
ich koche mit silikon werkzeug und es
sind also viele kunden gehört zu den
kunststoffen und kunststoffe sind
wirklich ganz viele verschiedene und
geradezu ikonischen wirklich
hochwertiger kunststoff dem nutzer zum
beispiel auch in der medizin da wieder
oft eingesetzt und das sage ich jetzt
mal die unterschiede früher das kenne
ich auch noch von meiner mama und ich
hatte holz kochlöffel die habt mal
benutzt und dann hat man sie mit der
hand spülen müssen
denn wenn man sie mal ähnlich
geschirrspülmaschine gegeben hat sind
dann natürlich kaputt gegangen sind
porös geworden
du hast den geschmack nicht mehr
rausgekriegt den geruch nicht mehr
rausgekriegt oder auch die farbe also
wenn ich was mit tomatenmark gekocht
habe war der kochlöffel hat roth den
nächsten drei wochen
und wenn ich zwiebeln angebraten habe
hat eben auch der milchreis nach
zwiebeln geschmeckt weil der kochlöffel
eben auch den geschmack immer wieder
abgegeben hat dann wurde in der
industrie edelstahl genommen und
edelstahl ist natürlich ein sehr sehr
gutes ein hochwertiges werkzeug da hat
man natürlich nur das problem dass wenn
man eine beschichtete pfanne hat zum
beispiel oder auch in einer schüssel
rührt die nicht aus metall besteht dass
man sich dann einfach sein werkzeug und
sein geschirr verkratzt und edelstahl
hat auch wenn es nicht gut verarbeitet
ist und der griff eben nicht gut gemacht
ist wird natürlich auch sehr schnell
heiß das heißt man kann sich eben auch
beim kochen verbrennen
dann gab es auch varianten oder gibts
halt natürlich leider immer noch die
varianten aus billigem kunststoff sowie
jetzt hier zum beispiel da habe ich
jetzt um fahnenbänder den gibt es glaube
ich für 49 cent im möbelhaus und dessen
schätzt um dinge ruhig sagen wird dessen
plastikteil weil es einfach nicht gut
ist das zeige sich auch gleich und
deswegen habe ich mich auch bei diesen
kunststoffen dagegen entschieden denn
bei denen passiert ist ganz gerne mal
dass sie einfach nicht hoch erhitzt sind
das heißt wenn es immer in der pfanne
vergisst dann schmelzen die oder sie
ziehen fäden
ich weiß noch meine mama hatte auch so
schwarzes geschirr die hat da mal was
frittiert und was rausgenommen und hier
unten haben sich ganz viele kleine
bläschen gebildet
hier sieht man zum beispiel auch dass es
hier auch schon geschmolzen und wieder
verhärtet ist und man möchte was halt
einfach nicht in seine lebensmittel mit
drin haben also das will man echt nicht
mit essen und das ist jetzt so ein
werkzeug was dann leider also dieses
plastik wasser mit meinem silikon werk
zu verglichen wird und aber auch bei
silicon gibt es unterschiede gibt's
wirklich gutes silikon werkzeug und
schlechteste league ohne werkzeug
genauso wie sie in gute und eben
schlechte milch gibt und jetzt zeige ich
euch hier mal habe ich jetzt einmal das
gute silikon dass ich das was ich
verwende und dieses hier ist es okay
aber ich zeige euch einfach mal die
kleinen unterschiede die man von außen
wirklich gar nichts seht also optisch
von außen betrachtet sehen die beiden ja
fast gleich aus bis auf die farbe jetzt
aber von der form her von der größe her
und vom gewicht her ist es ein bisschen
leichter
aber wenn man das ganze doch mal näher
betrachtet sieht man folgendes ich zeige
es bei dem dieses silikon was ich
benutze hat halt dem innen und peter
stahl kern das heißt es ist wirklich
sehr stabil zerbricht nicht wird nicht
heiß und außen habe ich eben ein
hochwertiges silikon und bei diesem
silikon ist es so da habe ich ihnen kein
edelstahl sondern ich habe hier im
kunststoff kern der einfach leicht
zerbricht das heißt wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel mal bei so einem großen
pfannenwender was schickes schweres
drauf habe ein dickes omelett habe
bricht dieses edelstahl silikon nicht
aber so ein löffel der bericht hat dann
eben mal schnell ab ich hab ich jetzt
mal einen hochwertigen silikon löffel
aufgeschnitten
mein herz hat natürlich geblutet dabei
aber um euch zu zeigen was da drin
steckt hat man wirklich so einen dicken
edelstahl kern und der kann dann
wirklich nicht brechen nicht kaputt
gehen und das ist eben das besondere
daran
und gerade wenn man jetzt größeres
werkzeug hat als jetzt nicht nur diese
kleinen löffel sondern eben auch hier
größere saucen löffel zum beispiel der
schall schön stabil bei dem habe ich
leider vorhin schon ich bin nicht stark
aber ich habe es vorhin leider schon
zerbrochen
und ja jetzt nochmal hier zum vergleich
als hirsch wirklich der tolle edelstahl
kern drin
und hier hat man wirklich gar nichts
drin also einem dünnen kleinen
kunststoff stift der wirklich einfach
ganz leicht abbricht und ich zeige euch
jetzt mal das silikon wirklich nicht
schmelzen kann ich habe jetzt hier
einmal dieses kunststoff und einmal den
silicon löffel in der pfanne und erhitzt
es jetzt einfach mal und zeigt euch was
passieren würde wenn man wirklich das in
der pfanne vergessen würde
[Musik]
also spreche das experiment jetzt hier
ab ich will keine vergiftung wir sind
hier nicht bei galilei ohne aber ich
zeige euch mal ganz kurz hier nichts
geschmolzen und das hier sieht ziemlich
eklig aus also das möchte ich nicht in
meinem bett am morgen drin haben und ich
glaube ihr alle auch noch schnell raus
wenn wir gerade noch beim silicon sind
mache ja auch mit silikon weiter und
zwar kennt ihr vielleicht von mir meinen
über kopfschutz den benutze ich gerne
zum beispiel wenn ich nudeln kochen
koche oder irgendwie eine suppe oder was
anderes milch zum beispiel was eben
einfach über kochen kann
da kommt dieser über kopfschutz auf den
topf dann kann das ganze nicht
überkochen weil dann einfach hier die
ganze brühe sage jetzt mal einfach hier
drinnen bleibt und dieses produkt ist
ein sehr hochwertiges produkt aber
natürlich gibt es mittlerweile auch also
das hier ist das original aber
mittlerweile geht es natürlich auch
viele plagiate zum beispiel und wir
wissen plagiate also nachgemachte sachen
sind einfach günstiger und billiger und
hier habe ich jetzt soll für so ein
plagiat das sieht auf den ersten blick
vielleicht mal gar nicht so anders aus
jetzt farblich natürlich die farbe nicht
betrachtet aber wenn man sich das dann
genauer ansieht sieht man dann
eigentlich ganz gut dass es eben doch
ein ganz anderes produkt ist jetzt
gerade hier zum beispiel mit der blume
im innern freundlich sind die ganze zeit
ausgefallen
der effekt game over aber auch bei dem
ist es jetzt zb so auf den ersten blick
erkennt man es nicht das heißt ihr müsst
euch da ein bisschen auskennen und bei
silikonen wissen was ich gutes silikon
und was schlechtes silikon bei gutem
silikon ist es so wenn ihr es hier
zusammendrückt dann sieht man hier
keinen farbunterschiede also ihr seht
hier passiert nichts
und wenn ich jetzt das plagiat nehme und
zusammendrücken oder auch jedes andere
silikon könnt ihr immer testen und das
zusammen drücke dann wird es hier weiß
und zwar kommt es daher dass hier für
stoffe mit drin sind als vorhin mit der
menschen mit dem wasser wird einfach das
silikon aufgefüllt um das produkt an
sich in der herstellung günstiger oder
billiger zu machen und diese füllstoffe
sind aber gerade bei silikon was erhitzt
werden soll also zb bei silicon
backformen oder bei sondern über
kopfschutz wirklich sehr schädlich denn
die sind gar nicht zugelassen also diese
nicht zugelassen dass man sie eben
erhitzen kann
ich habe hier zum beispiel meinen löffel
ab klage das ist schon sehr gutes und
sehr hochwertiges produkt auch hier
könnt ihr den schnelltest machen
hier habe ich jetzt auch diese
füllstoffe drin aber ich sag euch warum
bei diesem produkt ist es so dieses
produkt wird nicht erhitzt das dient
lediglich als löffel ablage hier auf der
arbeitsfläche da lege ich hübschen
schmalen den löffel ab und erhitze es
nicht von daher ist es hier egal ob
füllstoffe mit drin sind oder nicht und
bei diesem produkt ist eher zum vorteil
von uns kunden denn das produkt soll ja
nicht unnötig teuer gemacht werden
und deswegen hat man hier eben dieses
silikon siliconprodukten allgemein muss
man wirklich darauf achten muss einfach
mal auch mit der nase dran gehen immer
dran riechen und wenn silikon stinkt
dann lasst wirklich die finger davon
denn es ist so das silikon produkte nach
der herstellung gepampert werden müssen
das heißt die werden in einem heißen
backofen ausgepackten und da entfliehen
einfach nochmal alle stoffe die eben
nicht auf den lebensmitteln mit drin
sein sollen
jetzt gibt's natürlich hersteller die
das nicht machen um eben kosten zu
sparen und dann passiert folgendes dann
kauft ihr euch zb eine silikon backform
machte den ersten tag rein in den
backofen und plötzlich stinkt eierkuchen
nach diesem silikon und das ganze haus
stehen nach diesem silikon weil dann ihr
praktisch zu hause das produkt
ausgebacken habt und es ist wirklich
nicht gut und sehr schädlich und daher
solltet ihr bei silikon produkten die
erhitzt werden
wirklich immer diesen schnelltest machen
und darauf achten dass sie eben nicht
die farbe verändern
natürlich muss man allgemein darauf
achten dass einfach die qualität stimmt
das heißt bleibt schön in form oder es
labbrig und verändert die form bleibt
hier zum beispiel diese blume ihnen
drinnen oder fällt sie weg oder bei
manchen plagiaten ihr steht blumen nicht
mal mehr drin
das heißt man hat im prinzip einen
deckel mit löchern drin setzen auf den
topf und es bringt euch aber gar nichts
denn der deckel dient ja dazu dass es
wasser eben schnell kocht aber eben auch
nicht überkocht normalerweise müsste es
ja wirklich so sein dass jedes produkt
war es in deutschland verkauft wird oder
hier erhältlich ist einfach ein
zertifikat hat das geprüft wird aber
mittlerweile kann man das ja gar nicht
mehr machen weil einfach so fiel auch im
ausland gekauft wird und importiert wird
und so vieles über die grenze kommt dass
es eben gar nicht mehr geht dass man
alles kontrolliert und deswegen sollte
die us-verbraucher euch wirklich das
selber informieren und euch anschauen
welche produkte gekauft und welche
wo kauft es natürlich auch ganz wichtig
genau das muss mich immer der importeur
draufstehen und es ist der in verkehr
bringt genau es ist immer der im verkehr
bringer ist dafür haftbar
aber wenn der als irgendwo im team butt
korrekt und die kopplung oder
rausgeschickt hat dann kann er nicht
mehr haftbar gemacht werden denn egal
und deswegen muss man immer gucken das
hat ja die vikare drauf sind und dass es
eine marke ist er mag ist klar auch
markenartikel wer geht es mal meine
rückrufaktion aber da könnt ihr
wenigstens sicher sein
es ist noch sachen geprüft werden genau
als nächstes zeige ich euch jetzt eins
meiner eigenen produkte die ich selber
herstellen lasse er wir sind ja alle war
kamen backend orten rahmen und da habe
ich jetzt seit einer weile meiner
eigenen produkte hier auch mit meinem
sally logo mit drauf und zwar deswegen
weil ich einfach bisher nie im produkt
gefunden hatte was mir und meinen
qualitäts anforderungen entsprochen hat
jetzt kann ich euch hier mal zeigen also
das ist jetzt natürlich sehr krasses
beispiel das habe ich hier aus dem
supermarkt gekauft ich glaube 699
gekostet und im prinzip sieht man es
schon wenn ich das hinstelle und zum
ausziehen was da einfach die
unterschiede sind jemand außer man
möchte natürlich seine frauen backen
ich glaube das möchte man nicht und zwar
ist wirklich so dass man sieht es
natürlich auf den ersten blick die
unterschiede sind mein back rahmen hat
nun fünf millimeter an wandstärke und
der hat nur 0,2 und das spiegelt sie
natürlich auch im preis wider
mein produkt ist zu 100 prozent in
deutschland hergestellt aus unserer
region
das war mir auch ganz wichtig dass der
hier hergestellt wird weil ich so eben
auch in den produktionsprozess
eingreifen kann ich kann meine wünsche
äußern ich kann änderungen vorschlagen
und ich kann einfach das produkt mit
entwickeln am habe ich zum beispiel wenn
man das jetzt mal so aussieht
da habe ich hier so eine führungsschiene
die ich wirklich durchgehend das heißt
der bug rahmen wird komplett gestützt
egal wie weit hinaus zieren und
und bei diesem produkt ist es einfach so
dass wirklich nur punktuell
das heißt ich habe hier diese zwei
punkte da wieder gestützt
ansonsten ist hier wirklich nur 0 2 mm
stärke und das sieht man einfach dass
dann der bug rahmen nicht rechtwinklig
ist sondern eben eine komische
rautenform oder so an dem tisch in
rotterdam
wenn es dann nach innen geht ich glaube
ich war schlecht bei ihnen die er in
geometrie das spiegelt sich natürlich
dann auch im preis wider aber weil so
produkten ist dann wirklich so den hier
benutzt man dann zwei drei mal und der
verformt sich dann auch der verschiebt
sich auch um macht eben nicht das tolle
ergebnis
und da ist wirklich so wer billig kauft
kauft zwei oder dreimal
jetzt habe ich hier noch ein produkt aus
meiner eigenen serie aus meiner stelle
reihe und zwar das backblech es bis vor
etwa einem jahr ungefähr hatte ich in
meinem online shop dieses backblech und
zwar ist es und praktisch zum ausziehen
und da habe ich eben gerne darauf
gebacken
mit der zeit musste ich aber leider
feststellen dass es backblech eben doch
nicht so toll war wie ich dachte
es hat sich beim backen zum beispiel
verzogen das heißt wenn ein extremer
temperaturunterschied da war zum
beispiel hat sich den backofen auf 250
grad vor schiebt den bug das backblech
mit dem teig hinein und das futter neben
plötzlich heiß dann hat es im ofen und
knall gegeben das backblech hat sich
dann das hat sich verzogen ist wirklich
hoch gekippt und der ganze tisch meer
ausgelaufen
und ich dachte krasses kann doch
eigentlich gar nicht sein und hat dann
ebenso festgestellt okay das backblech
ich doch nicht so gut wie ich es fand am
anfang und was ich am schlimmsten auch
noch fand das gar nicht gut reinigen
kann das heißt es darf nicht in die
spülmaschine weil es einfach so diese
antihaftbeschichtung hat und ich durfte
zum beispiel auch keinen aggressiven
reiniger benutzen also nur spüle in ganz
weichen schwamm keine spülbürste weil
ansonsten einfach dieses blech die
oberfläche sich aufgelöst hat
ich hab das dann natürlich auch aus dem
shop rausgenommen weil der hersteller
eben nicht bereit war das backblech so
zu verändern dass es eben den
qualitätsanforderungen entspricht
und deswegen haben wir das rausgenommen
und ich habe jetzt wirklich ganz ganz
lange mit einem hersteller hier aus
unserer region etwas ausgetüftelten
blech entwickelt und zwar so dass es
wirklich so ist wie ich es mir wünschen
dass sie lieber
flächig es wirklich so schrecklichen
premium backblech und die profis unter
euch die kennen das auch schon die haben
es auf der messe schon gesehen und ich
bin da jetzt auch wirklich sehr
begeistert davon dass besteht zu 100 aus
edelstahl aus massivem edelstahl
also wenn man es auch mal in der hand
hat das ist auch wirklich ziemlich
schwer und es ist auch ein backblech zum
ausziehen
das heißt ich kann es einmal am anfang
auf meine backblech auf meine backofen
größe einstellen und dann habe ich die
perfekte größe und hier seht ihr auch
schon im und im vergleich
das heißt die update zum beispiel auch
diese ganz vielen großen löcher
na klar sind ja auch dafür da dass der
teig eben richtig schön kross durch
packt aber die sind eben dafür
konstruiert dass das blech sich auch bei
der größten wärme bei den größten wärme
schwankungen eben ausgleichen kann und
das blech sich an sich eben nicht
verzählt
und das hat man hier bei diesem blech
eben nicht hier sind kleine löcher und
es ist sowieso kein edelstahl das heißt
es verzieht sich auch wirklich schon bei
200 grad und die reinigung ist mir immer
ganz besonders wichtig denn ich möchte
nicht in der küche stehen 20 minuten
kuchen backen und drei stunden das blech
schrubben
das heißt ihr könnt dieses blech dann
auch in die spülmaschine stellen oder
auch einfach mal ein bisschen dran
schrubben da kann nichts passieren es
kann nicht rosten ist aus edelstahl und
das habe ich hier eben nicht
und bei diesem blech ist halt so dass
wenn du jetzt irgendwie das blech so ein
bisschen verkratzt dann rost ist eben
auch an dieser stelle und der hersteller
sichert sich in dem fall einfach dadurch
ab dass er sagt ihr dürft zeit nicht
verkratzen ihr dürft nicht truppen ihr
dürft nicht steuern
und im prinzip ist daneben eure eigene
schuld jetzt eckert ihr euch vielleicht
falls ihr dieses günstigere blech damals
bei mir gekauft habe ich ärgere mich
selber darüber aber es ist leider kein
reklamations grund und ich habe auch
wirklich ziemliche probleme mit dem
hersteller
er wollte blecher einfach nicht
zurücknehmen deswegen kann ich von mir
aus sagen ich kann mich anbieten falls
ihr dieses blech habt unzufriedenheit
und die rechnung noch habt dass ihr uns
das zurücksenden könnt und im gegensatz
dazu dann bei diesem blech einfach den
preis reduziert bekommt also dass wir
jetzt so ein angebot von mir an euch
weil ich einfach nicht möchte dass er
unzufrieden zeitweilig wirklich bei
diesem produkt vollkommen zu 100
dahinter stehen und da bei diesem blech
leider erst nach ein paar mal benutzten
die fehler aufgetaucht sind
das war jetzt ein paar kleinere
beispiele und jetzt zeige ich euch noch
ein großes beispiel und zwar bei den
küchenmaschinen da kann man wirklich den
größten fehlkauf eigentlich machen
ich habe ja seit langem die kitchenaid
und bei der kitchen aid oder auch bei
der kennwort ist das zum beispiel so das
sind wirklich sehr hochwertige geräte
hirsch wirklich alles aus hochwertigem
metall gemacht es ist eisen
die edelstahl töpfe sind wirklich sehr
hochwertig kann die mit in die
geschirrspülmaschine geben dir element
dessen hochwertig und an sich ist die
maschine eben auch sehr schwer da hab
ich aber auch ein eigenständiges
küchenmaschinen video schon gemacht da
könnt ihr euch das auch gerne mal
anschauen und im vergleich dazu habe ich
jetzt hier eine sehr günstige maschine
stehen eine nähmaschine trikots auch
schon 90 und jetzt auch als findet sich
auch schon viel geld dafür dass man es
eben für sowas ausgibt ich hatte ganz am
anfang auch so einer küchenmaschine zwar
eine weise aus dem discounter die hatte
mir meine schwester nämlich damals
geschenkt die kamera
danke dafür ihren ersten lust auf video
der nicht so viel und die maschine war
nicht lange im gebrauch und da ist schon
passiert dass mir einfach elemente
kaputt gingen
jetzt sieht man auch hier spricht vieles
den hof machen und die ganze maschine
gibt um
naja soviel dazu bei den maschinen die
sind einfach so günstig weil alles was
man im prinzip an hochwertigem material
austauschen kann
wurden hier durch kunststoff ersetzt die
maschine ist sehr leicht und hat
deswegen unten diese saugnäpfe die jetzt
schon kaum funktionieren aber jetzt
stellt euch mal vor ihr habt die
maschine einen betrieb da funktionieren
die gar nicht mehr und wenn ich dann
hier drin einen hefeteig knete einen
teig kneten höre dann passiert einfach
folgendes die maschine wird nicht mehr
auf der arbeitsfläche stehen bleiben und
irgendwann runterfallen
mit der zeit werden diese weise
maschinen dieser kunststoff wird dann
auch irgendwann gelb ihr kennt das
vielleicht auch wenn die einfach zu
lange stehen dann vergibt das alles und
sie blickt ganz ganz furchtbar aus und
was ich ganz kraft findet ihn einfach
die ruhr elemente die sind halt hier
teilweise nur aus metall also zumindest
die drähte hier aber hier oben hat man
einfach diesen kunststoff knopf und da
ist das problem dass irgendwann diese
drehte sich hier ablösen
so war es auch bei meiner maschine und
ich musste sie dann wegschneiden damit
ich mich nicht in
verletze und damit ich eben weiter
arbeiten kann und irgendwann glauben 34
drehte weg und dann bringt mir hat auch
der schneebesen nichts mehr
und weil mein gerät was so da es ein
nebenprodukt war gab es eben auch keine
ersatzteile
das heißt ich habe die komplette
maschine entsorgen müssen und hätte mir
im prinzip noch mal die gleiche kaufen
müssen und da finde ich es halt ein
absoluter fehlkauf und bevor man eben 90
euro für so eine maschine ausgeht 90
oder 140 euro da gibt es auch schon
bisschen teurer aber eben auch noch
nicht hochwertiger holt man sich lieber
ein gutes handrührgerät und verzichtet
eben am anfang auf eine küchenmaschine
und den einzigen fehler den man wirklich
machen kann wenn man sich hochwertige
produkte holt wie zum beispiel kennt
oder kitchenaid ist dass man sich das
falsche gerät für den falschen gebrauch
holt das heißt ich würde auch jeden tag
wirklich angeschrieben beantworte
unzählige e-mails womit die frage
gestellt wird sally welche die maschine
soll ich mir holen und ich stelle dann
immer zuerst die frage kochst du mehr
wachstum mehr
was möchtest du mit der maschine machen
und post überhaupt eine maschine
denn der größte fehler ist dass man sich
wirklich so ein tolles teures gerät holt
und das dann einfach nicht benutzt und
das ist dann wirklich auch fehl am platz
das war jetzt nur ein paar beispiele ich
hätte euch glaube ich den ganzen
haushalt ausschütten können aber ich
wollte einfach nur mit wenigen guten
beispielen zeigen worauf ihr wirklich
beim kauf achten könnt mir ist immer
ganz wichtig gerade bei den produkten
die ich selbst entwickeln dass sie
qualitativ gut sind aber eben nicht nur
die qualität zählt sondern auch wo kommt
das produkt her wie wir jetzt
hergestellt herrschender faire
arbeitsbedingungen gibt es da faire
löhne
wir sind die umweltstandards das sind
einfach aspekte die mir persönlich sehr
wichtig sind und ich auch immer versuche
wirklich zu beachten
natürlich kann man nicht jedes produkt
in der region herstellen
das geht einfach nicht bisher war es bei
mir so mies gelungen alle meine eigenen
produkte aus der region in der region
herstellen zu lassen
aber es gibt auch produkte die können
gar nicht in deutschland österreich der
schweiz oder in frankreich hergestellt
werden
es gibt produkte gibt es halt eben nicht
in europa so wie zum beispiel die
kitchenaid die wird in den usa
hergestellt aber auch da ist es ganz
wichtig ich war ja auch vor ort habe mir
das ganze angeschaut daher schon faire
arbeitsbedingungen faire löhne
und es ist ja auch wirklich so jeder von
uns jeder von euch möchte selber ver
bezahlt werden möchte einen tollen
arbeitsplatz und deswegen ist natürlich
auch wichtig dass man verein kaufte um
eben auch anderen diesen fairen
arbeitsplatz
sichern zu können man muss auch mal
anderen können genau auch sagen und klar
es gibt auch produkte die können gar
nicht hergestellt werden die müssen dann
in asien hergestellt werden aber selbst
stark aber darauf achten dass sie dort
in dem betrieb hergestellt werden wo
eben fair bezahlt wird fair trade waren
ja wo einfach eben auch gewisse umwelt
dort an das geachtet politik genauso und
war
und ja ich wurde einfach in mit diesem
video zeigen worauf man beim kauf achten
kann oder dass man eben auch mal etwas
nicht kaufen muss sondern lieber also
lieber hole ich mir etwas hochwertiges
startet mir etwas zu holen was eben
nicht gut ist und lieber verzichtet dann
auch im produkt als ein billiges produkt
zu holen und da kann man auch mal drauf
sparen und sich darauf freuen und hat
dann eben auch was gutes hinterhand und
hat kein geld verschwendet kein geld
rausgeschmissen und den müllberg
irgendwo vergrößern auch lenggenwil
ernst dieser zeit genau das sind was
sagen die längst soweit unsere köpfe
hinter früh meine mama hat uns zur
hochzeit weggeholt es waren eben statt
töpfe mit so einem sandwich boden haben
glaube ich 100 euro oder so wir kosteten
fed für uns war das damals viel geld
muss man dazu sagen ich so wenn man noch
student ist und die töpfe die waren okay
aber sie war nicht gut und mit dem umzug
haben was ihr dann entsorgen müssen weil
die nicht induktions geeignet waren und
dann haben wir uns ja für 35 eures darf
man gar nicht sagen
ein topfset in seinem möbelhaus gewohnt
und sie haben wirklich grottenschlecht
aber ein topf video ein eigenes habe ich
auch schon gemacht ist bekommt ihr auch
demnächst wo ich einfach zeige wie ja
fast nur weil dem topf achten kann man
kann auch nur das beste vom besten wohl
mit seinem bankberater ein bisschen er
ja genau das geht auch nicht man kann
ich immer das beste von allem haben man
muss einfach prioritäten setzen
bei mir ist es so ich hab keinen teuren
schmuck ich habe keine teuer habe ich
habe nur ein bisschen kosmetik
ich habe dann eben kein zwei meter
schrank und ich lege wert auf
qualitative produkte in meiner küche
weil ich damit jeden tag arbeite jeden
tag in der küche stehe und mir einfach
meine ernährung um ein ersten eben
wichtig ist bei anderen sind dann eben
andere sachen und ja da kann ich im
prinzip nur sagen was mir eben
persönlich wichtiger ist ich hoffe dass
ich euch mit diesem video ein paar tipps
geben konnte vielleicht ein paar
fehlkäufe vermeiden kann oder vermeiden
können
und ja es ist massereich gefallen hat
und jetzt ist man was unterschied
zwischen billig und preiswertes genau
jetzt wissen wir was der unterschied
zwischen billig und preiswert ist will
ich für mich eigentlich schon
schimpfwort billigsten produkte
unterster schublade so einfach preis
leistung nicht stimmt weil das produkt
so schlecht ist dass man eigentlich gar
nichts dafür bezahlen dürfte und etwas
muss preiswert sein das heißt damit
preiswert und das ist wichtig denn ich
denke auch nicht genau denke ja sagte
schwabe sogar der schwabe sagt ist und
ich hoffe dass sich dieses video
gefallen hat dass es informativ handelt
und dass er ein paar tipps und tricks
mit tipps tricks sind bekommen habt also
ich freue mich auf euer feedback und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder biss
dann tschüss chips und zu bringen steht
später wieder zurück ja meistens billig
ich gut
billig ist billigpreis wirklich super
dass es am besten ist umsonst
das kann euch noch von uns bekommen